once you find the fish on the fish
finder you find a group of fish we send
dolphin Dan in big healthy believin dude
who was a phenomenal swimmer and he can
literally dive down 150 feet just in a
big hold the breath and hang out down
there for 34 minutes and kind of look
around and then swim back up so we're
sitting up there kind of going are you
find the fish yet no okay go check over
there and Dan would go down and go down
100 feet and come up and he could do
this all day he's he's he's amazing so
then he'd hop in once we find the fish
and we'd all throw her scuba gear on and
then he'd jump in again and stay with
them until it was exactly the right time
because if we jump into early you
battery's dead your stuffs down you only
have a couple hours you're out of air
and you missed the event so we have to
make sure that we leave at the exact
right time and then when he releases the
sausage and you see this red sausage at
the top it's go time you're in your you
have to be ready to go so cameras ready
batteries on all your filters are right
you have to make sure everything's right
because once that sausage hits the
surface you're you're in the water and
it's going to be go go go go from that
point on
so we both dive over and it's kind of
free for all the whole buddy system kind
of goes to hell you keep an eye on each
other back but you're it's such a frenzy
and it's such a mad chaotic event down
there that you just you're kind of on
your own and then you find yourself in
this cloud of fog and your don't know
where anybody is and you see a black
shape and swim towards units a bull
shark in you're like oh god and you know
you can't find your buddies and you come
up to the surface and can't through the
boat and go back down you film and so
it's you know it's it's kind of chaotic
you lose all sense of place and it can
be scary but uh but in the end it's
really just a lot of fun